president Donald Trump is facing war on
all fronts he's been accused of
insensitivity toward a gold star a
widowed former future president Hillary
Clinton is slamming his North Korea
strategy as dangerous and rumors swirl
over a ban an induced White House
conflict with Mitch McConnell will
discuss the fallout then Alicia Kraus
amber Athey and Amanda Prestidge
jacquimo joined the panel of deplorable
zs-- to talk gay Nazi Jews Rand Paul's
smacking around John McCain and Lindsey
Graham and elementary schools canceling
Halloween in favor of the politically
correct orange and black spirit day I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
we have so much to get to today we it's
just War World War the whole time Alicia
Krause from the conversation at the
Daily wire is making her panel of
deplorable stay beyou but before we get
to any of that I have very good news
especially for me but I guess for all of
us we have a new sponsor we have a
sponsor we're gonna keep the lights on
we're gonna job we're gonna keep my cup
full of coffe fa for maybe a week or two
longer uh we we have to talk about
stamps calm stamps calm is great I've
been saying these sponsors are all kind
of providential because they speak to my
deepest most central desires
I am a millennial I'm a member of the
much-maligned millennial generation the
one thing about Millennials I speak from
experience and from the heart we want
everything like right now we want it
on-demand we can get everything on
demand I don't want to have to go to the
post office I don't want to have to go
to any brick-and-mortar store I get
everything exactly to either my couch or
my desk that's exactly where I want it
I've begun to meld in with this chair
stamps.com can give that to you anything
that you can get at the post office you
can do right from your desk with stamps
com
so you can buy and print official US
postage for any letter or package using
your own computer and printer do it
right down the hall for me I'm not even
gonna go get it I'm gonna have Marshall
go run down and get it you know cuz
we're shipping out blank book after
blank book at this place yes and I just
don't want to go to the post office I
don't want to wait in line I want to
have it right at my desk
unlike the post office stamps calm never
closes so usually I'll procrastinate at
7 or 8 hours before I do anything even
get a cup of coffee and by the time I do
that all the stores are closed
stamps.com Union do it right right from
where you are whenever you want at 3 in
the morning which is when I do most of
my work in the old days you know there
used to be these postage meters
Marshalls obviously too young to
remember this but it's how businesses
would post for their packages and for
their letters if they would always break
they were always clunky it wasn't a
really not a good system this is way
more streamlined much more modern it's
the it's just the way to mail things
these days so right now
and by the way this is the real reason
you got to give these guys some love
they they made my promo code cough FA Co
V Fe Fe so right now if you go over to
stamps com use my code make sure you use
my code it's it's up in the top corner
right by the microphone when you go to
the home page type in cough F a promo
code cough FA Co V Fe Fe at stamps comm
enter cough FA and never go to the
post-office again and help us keep the
lights on okay we've got so much to get
to right now let's begin with this story
that's all over the news Florida
congresswoman Frederica Wilson it's
always some Florida woman has come out
swinging against President Trump with an
allegation that one of her constituents
a Goldstar Widow received a phone call
from Trump after her son sergeant Lee
David Johnson was killed in niger two
weeks ago a Wilson alleged that this is
the congresswoman alleged that Trump
told told the widow quote well I guess
he knew what he signed up for but I
guess it still hurt we don't know what
he said you know we do know that this
Florida congresswoman is pretty kooky
and she comes from a far left
ideological background she famously
introduced a congressional resolution to
honor Trayvon Martin she called for
Trump's impeachment a couple months ago
and she wears these weird hats all the
time
the timing is also a little coincidental
just a couple days ago Trump suggested
that Obama didn't call gold star
families when soldiers were killed in
action now we have this Democratic rep
swinging back a great guy on Twitter
Matt's ideas shop laid it out fairly
well in a likely unlikely diagram
because look Trump may have said
something to that effect he's not
exactly the most eloquent guy in the
world he might have said something to
the effect of my condolences your
husband made the ultimate sacrifice he
bravely enlisted he he knew what he
signed up for he's ready to give his
life he's a hero so that's one version
of this some some series of those kind
of lines or he might have said hey yo
it's me the Donald your husband know
what he signed up for are we cool what
do you think it is I don't I'm sorry I
don't care how in our
particulate Donald Trump can be I don't
think it was the latter I
he may have said some comment to that
effect but the Democratic congresswoman
who's made this a cudgel given the
timing and given her past history I
think it is worth questioning what her
political motives are here regardless
the the really sad thing about this
episode is that there's a brave American
sergeant Lee David Johnson who made the
ultimate sacrifice for our country for
my freedom and for yours and he's now
being used as a blunt political cuddle
by a cynical Democrat congresswoman it's
really awful and and we shouldn't give
it we should address it obviously we
should address the allegations but we
should not spend more time talking about
this the cynical woman this this
democratic propagandist that even even
if she's alluding to some truthful
comment here is obviously twisting it
for political purposes in other war
related news my battle ax of a cousin
Hilary Clinton is despicably mouthing
off on foreign soil
the former future president slammed
president Trump's North Korea policy as
quote dangerous and short-sighted today
during a speech in South Korea she
alleged quote picking fights with Kim
jong-un just puts a smile on his face I
think the real quote went like but we
were translating it obviously for for
the American audience
the irony defies reason but then the
Clintons are immune to shame Donald
Trump is clemens von Metternich compared
to Hillary Clinton let's just establish
that first she has no credibility here
her disastrous handling of foreign
affairs from the failed Russia reset to
her awful handling of crises in Egypt
and Libya and elsewhere in the world it
should disqualify her from saying boo
about geopolitics but more than that she
and particularly her husband bear the
lion's share of the blame for the North
Korean nuclear crisis that we find
ourselves in in 1994 people might not
remember this Bill Clinton refused to
respond when Kim Jong Il pursued nuclear
weapons and when Kim Jong Il refused to
allow weapons inspectors to review two
of his nuclear waste sites in complete
violation of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty then Hillary
Clinton
not just first lady she was also later
Secretary of State she executed a North
Korea strategy known as this is not a
joke strategic patience strategic
patience you you couldn't make that up
in political satire and that strategic
patience was very unstraight because it
only allowed the threat to grow
president Trump and Secretary of State
Tillerson their handling of North Korea
has apparently been pretty good so far
from from what we can tell it's very
hard we're getting mixed signals we
don't really we're not dead and we're
not de we haven't been obliterated yet
you know he Trump secured the release of
that american student otto warmbier who
was jailed by the Kim regime during the
Obama administration but fine Hillary is
bitter that she lost the presidency
twice she can't get over it she's
clearly being ripped apart from the
inside out who cares
the real offense here is that she's
criticizing US policy on foreign soil
there has long been a taboo against
doing this you know we have robust
political debates at home and then
abroad American citizens are supposed to
present a united front they're supposed
to refrain from criticizing the present
policy overseas Hillary however is
immune from shame patriotism be damned
my cousin what a what a traumatic family
reunion this will be next year
the third battlefront the president
Trump faces right now is the apparently
Steve Bannon induced war between the
White House and Mitch McConnell
president Trump standing next to
McConnell at this press conference
claimed quote my relationship with this
gentleman is outstanding very Trump he
endures for the exclamation point at the
end
McConnell echoed this he said contrary
to what some of you have reported we are
together totally on this agenda to move
America forward
but then Donald Trump in typical fashion
went on to say that he also quote
totally understands the frustrations of
Steve Bannon and Bannon plans to run
primaries against congressional
leadership and establishment Republicans
Bannon has declared hashtag war on the
Republican establishment and the
conservative establishment for that
manner for analysis on this last bit on
the ban in McConnell Trump who knows
what's happening we have to bring on our
expert panel of deplorable z-- an
all-female panel just to celebrate
Harvey
steena in Hollywood falling apart we
decided to bring all the ladies on the
show today
we have in Marathi from the Daily Caller
we have Amanda presto Giacomo from The
Daily wire and making her panel of
deplorable 'z debut we have Alicia
Krause our old friend Alicia Kraus who
you might have seen on the conversation
yesterday with Andrew Clavin and now the
Daily wires very own ladies thank you
for being here thanks
first question Alicia in the war between
Trump McConnell and Bannon who was
winning haha
I don't know that Bannon is at war with
Trump I have this kind of conspiracy
theory that he is working behind the
scenes and talking to Donald is like I
got your back bro and he really is doing
these things to it that he thinks maybe
are helping Donald Trump I think that I
think that Bannon might be winning this
game though because as we saw in the
Alabama primary or the Alabama race down
there and ended up being bannon's guy
that won not Trump's guy and I think
that Trump would like to blame Mitch
McConnell for that I don't know if
that's gonna end up coming out on if
he's gonna end up you know coming out on
top with that argument but I think that
Bannon is apparently recruiting
candidates across the country to pursue
and push forward legislation and agendas
that Bannon thinks are what Trump should
be doing that he isn't doing anymore and
that's how Bannon positions his exit
from the White House I said I mean I'm
not being fired I was always gonna leave
I can help Trump a lot more from the
outside than I can on the inside maybe
that's true maybe it is an Amber is
Bannon just trying to position himself
in the best possible light at trying to
make himself seem like a player here I
think that's what ben ben shapiro
suggested earlier today or is he acting
on behalf of the White House like Alicia
thinks I think it's a little bit of both
I think Alicia is right that Bannon is
probably of the mindset that he's
helping Trump by opposing these
supposedly anti Trump candidates but at
the same time I don't think he really
has as much power as he lets on when you
look at the Alabama race Roy Moore was
already really really popular and slated
to win that race so I'm not sure how
much of an effect Bannon really had
there and if you consider the fact that
he thinks that being at Breitbart gets
him a lot of power that would mean that
places like the Daily Caller and The
Daily wire would also be able to you
know shape a lot
troll races and I'm just not sure that
that's really the case oh I feel no
offense does yeah I don't know I kind of
feel like I can zap lightning out of my
fingers or something but maybe that's
just a difference of reaction
Amanda Trump has been saying very nice
things about Mitch McConnell regardless
of the Bannen dynamics regardless of
whether they're working in collusion
he's been saying nice things about like
one of the most detested Republicans in
the country pigs are flying on a cold
day in hell how long will the bromance
last as long as it's beneficial to trump
I mean he'll he can turn on McConnell at
the drop of the Hat so it's Trump knows
how to play this game better than anyone
if you think it's beneficial to you know
cozy ups to McConnell and have that
presser with Earl bloody buddy then
he'll do it and then the second he wants
to put the blame back on McConnell he
will and we've seen that before so it's
just whatever is beneficial to Trump
he'll spin it in a way that you know
it's it you know McConnell's good or bad
whatever people are knocking him because
they say he has a tough relationship
with the truth you know he says one
thing one day says one thing the next I
actually really like it I do think the
New Yorker thing is is it play with my
read on that because that is just how
New Yorkers talk they'll come out
they'll say oh yeah I love this guy he's
like a brother to me yeah he's he's
doing the great look in the back yeah
and then the next you know the next day
if he if if McConnell stabs Trump in the
back he'll say he's a total loser I hate
his guts and who cares you know there's
like a and then he'll come back around
his um I don't say dishonesty but his
relationship with the truth I think it's
sort of guileless here he's very open
you know that Donald Trump is gonna do
that see you know the minute McDonald
turns on him it's gonna be
no-holds-barred yeah and it helps him
kind of push whatever he wants for it
because they know that he's you know oh
I'm in his good graces no for the second
so they know them along that way gotta
love it it's that that's that I think I
compared him to met her knee earlier in
the show that that's the I don't know if
future historians will recognize the
political genius of Donald Trump but
they probably should he's actually been
working at a much
and I think a lot of people gave him
credit for okay we've got a lot more
news to get to we we have to get to the
war on Halloween before the war on
Christmas there's now we're on Halloween
there is so much to talk about but if
you don't subscribe to the daily wire
you can't see the rest of it we
appreciate all the current subscribers
you're helping keep the lights on you're
helping keep cuff fa and like in my
tumblr but for the rest of you go over
there right now you'll get me you'll get
the Andrew Clavin show you'll get the
Ben Shapiro show all that it's just $10
a month or $100 for an annual membership
but I know you're thinking that's a lot
of shows who cares whatever but look at
this guys look at this
the leftist tears tumblr filled to the
brim with coffe FA right now yeah this
is the finest mechanism for drinking
tasty leftist ears in the country this
the vintage we've prepared here is
actually from South Korea it's from so
laughter Hillary Clinton's speech
obviously it's not a limited run because
Hillary Clinton has been spouting salty
leftist ears for nine months now and
really for the better part of 30 years
but you can have that vintage can be
yours if you go to the daily wire calm
right now we'll be right back
an Englishman who has spent 40 years as
an active member of a white supremacist
movement has announced that he is a gay
Jew and he's retiring from neo Nazism
Alysha we're talking about a Jewish
neo-nazi here do we have a clip of this
guy were you thinking of your mom
no why not because because that term the
Jews you're presenting a global faceless
mass of people you know you can't
personalize these you can't see an
individual there that's not even your
mom no and that's the sort of
generalization that results in six
million people being deliberately
murdered we've heard this term Jewish
neo-nazi before that's what all the
crazy campus lefties call been every
time he shows up there this guy it's a
really interesting interview he explains
that he joined the neo-nazis and the
white nationalists and all that because
he was a loner basically he didn't have
any friends he didn't have anything to
do do you think I don't want to get into
too much psychobabble yeah do you think
that explains some of these all right
guys - I'm not talking about the Peppe
people who mischievous I'm talking about
the real racist neo-nazi types Richard
Spencer and does that social ostracism
explain their political actions I may be
potentially I think this also ties into
the hashtag me to campaign bear with me
for a moment
I think Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro
pointed out really good points that when
society doesn't have a standard that's
set of like what real men need to do and
then manliness in general by many in the
leftist feminist movement is kind of poo
pooed on and looked down on then
unfortunately sometimes you have men
that look to the wrong types of groups
to create those friendships and those
standards of decency that are like
really bad and shouldn't be followed and
then once they become a part of that
group they adhere to all those ideas
because they don't want to lose their
circle of friends on a very extreme
level we've seen this with Isis and how
Isis targets young men specifically on
Twitter and in educational you know
places and in some radical mosques
around the world and I think that it
make sense that the KKK and these
neo-nazi groups would be recruiting
people and members in the same way but I
mean his interview was really impactful
and a friend of the program Bethany
Mandel has pointed out that when you
target those people in a good way and
befriend them and show them the face of
women Christians Jews gay people black
people they have a really hard time than
just identifying hatred toward the
entire group because I've gotten to know
you as an individual of course I love
that dynamic they're the individual
versus these collective group identities
and yeah I think that's certainly the
case even with the me to comparison
there there is not in the culture and an
ideal of what masculinity should look
like what manliness should look like I
think it's the same with these neo-nazi
types they say they're defending Western
civilization but they don't really
understand what Western civilization is
or adhere to those values so they say we
want to protect Christendom but we want
nothing to do with Christianity yeah
that absolutely excellent analogy
amber lefties call anybody on the right
racist fascist neo-nazi whatever they
have they accuse us of hate just as they
would accuse David Duke of hate or
Richard Spencer how do we make sure that
we don't wake up someday or woke up
probably is more like it and disavow all
of the views that we hold right now how
do we know that we're not as crazy and
awful as they say that we are well part
of the reason why we're not going to
wake up one day and disavow our views is
because for what our views are rooted in
truth are not eightfold bigoted views as
the left would have us believe so we
kind of have an advantage over the
people who are actually neo-nazis
because we are grounded in some kind of
truth and value do you think that these
neo-nazi guys don't you think these
neo-nazi guys think that their racial
theories are rooted in truth you know
and when we just have we have other
theories that we ground our political
views in how do we know that we have the
right one said we know that we have the
true ones man you just went full lefty
on me you know I think it's it shows why
why it's so important to be really
we're full about how we label people and
how we collectivize people because if
you're going by that standard then
anyone could be enough anyone could be a
neo-nazi anybody could be hateful we
could easily turn that turn term around
on the left and accuse them of being
neo-nazis and if they defend it you can
just say well of course you don't think
you are because you don't want to you
know you don't want to face yeah
absolutely
it's really dangerous right yeah exactly
so it just shows how important language
is and how people will if you overuse
terms they start to lose his meaning and
they start to lose their value and we
easily could turn that term around on
them I mean a lot of the premises that
are shared by these far fringy extremist
racial groups yeah neo-nazis or whatever
or premises that are indulged in by the
left that racial group identity is is
what defines a person rather than a
person's soul inequality before God and
individuality by the way I think that's
why we're not going to woke up some day
and realize that really we should have
been you know lefty social justice
warriors is because they're their
premises are similarly wrong to those
neo-nazi premises and as Alicia
suggested you know we're the ones who
are saying look at the individual judge
the individual you know we're all all
created in God's image and we have to
live out those ideas that have been that
have caused the west and that have been
developed in the West but part of these
problems I mean not to get to
theological here but I get ideological
we're delving into Shiite Catholicism on
this show so please are you know it
created in the image of God and that's
where our belief in natural law starts
and the Equality of man starts but
unfortunately in our culture leftist
have distanced God from the involvement
of human importance right our human
value especially I mean look at what
they do to babies in utero and so
therefore that individualism isn't
important to them because they do like
the group think of you you are this and
this group is more important than this
because it's more politically
appropriate or it can be a political use
to them and a tool to them at that time
and it started years and years ago with
the growth of you know
progressivism and that movement away
from where does natural law come from
and the belief and our founders that you
know this has to come from God and this
is where this right came from and it's
not being taught to kids today I mean I
was hashtag homeschool of 12 years but
I've even talked to fellow home
schoolers and other Millennials I'm a
grandma malonyl you're on the younger
millennial age you know I'm a few years
older than you it isn't taught to an
entire swath of Americans and it hasn't
been for 20 plus years so really I think
in order to not wake up one day and to
answer your question a little bit we
have to start training people of where
those rights come from and what what you
know America really stands for and
that's that's where it begins it doesn't
begin when you're donating to
politicians it's a lot earlier than that
and it's how the left has gained so much
ground Amanda this guy was a member of
the National Front it's a very fringy
for right UK political party it doesn't
have any seats in parliament or anything
it's fuscia stick it's nationalistic is
there any fear for us that good old red
white and blue American nationalism
American patriotism that it will morph
into a grotesque like National Front
racial populism I mean there's always
the threat of that I suppose I mean
we've seen it you know it's basically
reactionary right like we've seen this
during the 2016 election or we had the
rise of the all right maybe a couple
years before that because the left as I
keep moving left they perpetuate this
groupthink identity politics to keep
moving that way and and and then plus on
top of that they called their opponents
you know racists and bigots and
homophobes and all and all this and that
you kind of have this reaction to kind
of you know kind of fill into that same
identity politics thinking and then kind
of fulfilling that prophecy that they
called you so sure there's there's
definitely a threat of that happening
and like I said we kind of have like
this very small minority of actual
potent white supremacist because again
all rights like I'm just saying the left
keeps pushing left and they keep playing
politics sure you can see a reaction and
then also I mean I don't know how PC
this is but I think you know a mixing of
demographics as we keep getting more
mixed and there's no assimilation that's
the key part when they're not adopting
American values you're gonna have some
conflict unfortunately so I think
assimilation is huge too that can kind
of you know push this this alt-right
movement a little you know give it more
prominence turn out that temperature in
that melting pot got to make it all melt
a little a little faster make a big
delicious American goop a nice fondue a
nice American fun do is what I want yeah
an elementary school in Massachusetts
has canceled Halloween they have
canceled Halloween for not being quote
inclusive enough in its place they will
now hold black and orange spirit day
amber is this white Trump one yeah
actually it is because this is just
another example of how people think it's
more important to not offend other sense
of other people's sensibilities and it
is to I don't know have fun or even just
promote truth you know I think this was
black and orange day sounds a little bit
racist you know throw in a term block
around like that was that about and
orange against people of of El
Presidente's descent all the time Google
actually it was being called out I think
it was yesterday because they added this
part to Google Maps or if you click on a
root they tell you how many calories you
can burn if you walk the route instead
of driving and then it's like oh if you
could burn 300 calories that's three
mini cupcakes and people got really
offended by that and we're really
triggered by it and like force them to
remove this so apparently offending
people is or not offending people is
more important than I don't know
combating the obesity epidemic in the
United States amber is a Kevon myself I
am deeply triggered by that I don't want
to know how many calories now I'm just
oh now all I can think about is cupcakes
the story of this Halloween story it
gets to my central theory of the left
that the left what it really wants is
the the Hollow
she'll the husk of an institution of a
great institution but not the animating
principle of it not all the stuff that's
inside so they drink decaf coffee they
get fancy university degrees without a
university education that you see it in
a lot of churches I think I actually
thought about this in Westminster it has
the husk the Anglican Church the husk of
a liturgy and traditional church but
it's gotten watered-down in a lot of its
principles and its dogma so it you know
it's been much like my dear alma mater
Yale has been invaded by the left and
hollowed out because of it is black and
orange day
Alicia is it actually different than
Halloween what is the difference here if
you change those words what what changes
I actually read this piece and I was
like wait a second is is this any
different than Halloween
they will take my daughter's elementary
school Halloween from like parade from
me within my cold dead hands it's like I
am all for the full family Halloween
Casa or amazing at Halloween seriously
if you like Halloween get married and
have kids and then you can enjoy it
forever like it is amazing but I I don't
know how different it is and it's so
funny because in their effort to not
offend anyone I think that they are
really offending more people I mean
Halloween is like a pagan holiday
growing up in the Bible Belt of America
like we couldn't celebrate Halloween we
had to dress up as Bible character do
this thing called a hell house were you
going you get scared by sin there's
actually people like that
they're there now they're trying to
appease the leftist like politically
correct people but they're probably like
unknowingly appeasing a lot of Southern
Baptists somewhere in the country it's
gonna have the opposite effect that they
intended tell them that and they will
immediately reinstate Halloween it'll be
a matter of minutes Amanda the reason
they canceled Halloween allegedly is
because Halloween is not inclusive
enough you know the holiday where you
dress up like whatever you want and get
a candy corn what is meant by inclusion
by these school administrators yeah I'm
so mad you asked me this because I had
the same question I was like I really
had no
I was like how how you can dresses
everything you want um I don't know
honestly this is kind of like Infowars
II but I don't know this is the
conspiracy central baby bring it to us
maybe there's like some religious I
don't know somebody complaining so they
want it like preemptively stop
everything and it's probably not a
Christian family I don't know I mean who
knows I mean I mean no one's terrified
of you know everything these days too
perhaps I just wanted to you know
preemptively appease people who are not
gonna celebrate Halloween and I don't
think it's the Christians that they're
looking out for so I don't know maybe
that's the good unintended consequence
of this it's like put the Christ back in
Christmas it's put the Hallows back in
Halloween put the Saints back in it I
don't know that's I'm always trying to
look on the bright side of these things
yeah actually I don't like Halloween
like I'm that oh I'm like a you know
inside I'm like a 75 year old southern
I'm like Baptist preacher like I I feel
all nice and like Saint Church am like I
don't like it that is so beautiful
because Amanda you do have a reputation
and you're in your writing of being a
little you know on occasion curmudgeonly
I do love the idea of like a little
trick or treater knocking on your door
he's ripped the candy from them have
everybody sing like hymns and that's
beautiful that's a beautiful thing very
Christian you're probably saving their
souls
moving on Senator Rand Paul has recently
slammed John McCain and Lindsey Graham I
know you're shocked he slammed them for
parading as conservatives Senator Paul
tweeted senators McCain and Graham are
torpedoing the budget by insisting on
busting the budget caps for more
spending Amanda this Rand Paul have any
credibility here he has been torpedoing
conservative legislation all year except
that he's doing it from a libertarian
perspective instead of from a
neoconservative perspective I gotta go
with Rand Paul here he's the only one
who somewhat sticks to conservative
libertarian like libertarian values and
yes he's been kind of a thorn in the
side of President Trump but as we just
saw with the health care thing he's you
know he helps with that executive order
to do a lot more
get rid of regulation so I think I mean
I don't want to sound like a chill for
for Rand Paul here but I feel like he's
actually trying to push something semi
libertarians semi conservative because
because my goodness I mean McCain and
Graham I mean they're you know they're
all the way on the Left I kind of think
that he does have some credibility just
because uh every now and then he'll
stick to his principles I will say I've
been hitting Rand Paul a lot in the last
few weeks because he's been completely
useless in the Senate recently but he is
on the side of fiscal responsibility
here he is he's brought up a term that
people have have not been discussing
even conservatives haven't been
discussing all year which is federal
spending which is the national debt
which is debt to GDP amber do you think
that in this age of cultural battles and
which is clearly what we're in it's
clearly what we elected Donald Trump to
do ken debt to GDP ratios still excite
conservatives gosh I really hope so I'm
reminded of the days back is from like
2008 to 2012 where the Tea Party was
really popular and they were all about
bringing down the national debt and even
if this isn't something that's super
popular among maybe Donald Trump space
there are still conservatives in
Congress who care about this we saw this
in all of these debates about the
disaster relief bills just yesterday a
bunch of conservatives voted against a
bill that would help were to reco
because they were upset that a lot of
the spending with wasn't going to
straight disaster relief I think mark
Meadows was among those Jim Jordan so
it's still something that they talked
about it's not as to the front of the
conversation as it used to be but I
think President Trump would be really
smart to get on board with lowering the
national debt because he loves to talk
about GDP growth and as we all know a 20
trillion dollar national debt is not
going to be super useful for growing the
economy when you have something like
ninety percent debt to GDP or approach
you know we Pro tching 100% debt to GDP
that is a drag on the economy it would
be nice if they did that back to McCain
Alicia John McCain has malignant brain
cancer it's unlikely that he will be
around this time next year but this guy
is gonna go down swinging he's gonna
swing against his political opponents
he's gonna probably swing against his
own brain cancer you got it even if you
don't agree with McCain on a lot of
things as I don't you do kind of have to
admire that spirit I mean this guy is
piss and vinegar
pretty much till the end do you do you
think that conservatives knowing that
John McCain is not long for this world
can we in good taste fight back against
his terrible legislative goals well one
I hope that he does fight this and when
I mean he is the maverick and I think
that that would have been something that
they should have pushed a little more
back in 2008 when he was running against
then-senator Barack Obama I think that
there are a lot of pros of McCain's
character and past experience that they
the you know people that were working on
the campaign didn't work on enough and I
think that they're still members of the
GOP in the Senate that can go to the
senator and and they can work together I
really don't think that he wants to go
down destroying his side of the aisle I
don't think that at all but I think it
could be interesting to see what happens
and listen I mean Rand Paul has been as
divisive to goals of the GOP as John
McCain and Lindsey Graham have so I
think that there just tends to be a lot
of attention on Senator McCain because
of where he is in his life and the
specific things he said about the
president that maybe Rand Paul isn't
saying right and I hope you know John
McCain is a mixed bag to conservatives
he has been a RINO for a long time but
he also has been a Republican fighter
before he ran for president in 2000 he
was pretty reliably on the right voted
pretty reliably with Republicans it
would be nice if in this last part of
his career if he would come back and
help us out and and affect some policy
rather than just run down trumps agenda
but I don't know I don't think he
watches my show we should make him some
things to be fair there are some things
in Trump's agenda that ain't so
conservative and so you know if if
McCain is going to run down the parts of
Trump's agenda that aren't conservative
then I am all for him in that way sure
sure but we hope we just hope
at something like Obamacare repeal or
something that should be a no-brainer
yeah you know that he'll he'll come
around on it but I guess we'll have to
wait and see that's our show today panel
thank you for being here amber Athey
from The Daily Caller Amanda Prestage
jacquimo from The Daily wire and first
time our our old pal
Alicia Krause can't wait to have you all
back I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show be sure to check out
my new podcast with Andrew Klavan it's a
narrative fiction Hollywood is falling
apart and we are pulling up some culture
hopefully and some can art from the
conservative side it's called another
Kingdom check it out on iTunes and on
ricochet and then also get your mailbag
questions in for tomorrow and we will
answer all of the questions that you
have for the entire rest of your life so
get it in I'm Michael Knowles this wagon
I'll show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]